[Music]
what's up guys
jared again perhaps no word describes
the humor of rick and morty more
precisely than
cynical what people call love is just a
chemical reaction that compels animals
to breed
the show has a reputation for taking the
piss out of anything one might consider
sacred whether it's religion existence
individuality or
family in particular the idea of marital
love has been taken down a few pegs
primarily through beth and jerry's
dysfunctional marriage but with them
reuniting at the end of season 3
can we expect a shift in the way the
show depicts love
episode 2 of season 4 was released last
weekend and although it's full of the
same rick and morty snark we've come to
eagerly expect
dad i want to say something i started
today disgusted and embarrassed to be
your son
and then later i thought we were gonna
die because you're a loser
there's no more nope now quit [ __ ] up
and let's go it also frames love in a
way that
makes the show seem a lot more wholesome
and positive than it possibly ever has
so let's find out if nihilism is getting
old in this quick take on rick and morty
season 4 episode 2
the old man in the seat and of course
spoilers ahead
okay let's dive into a quick recap rick
is on the hunt for the man who used his
secret pastoral toilet
while his monogatron intern gluti
convinces jerry to help him develop an
app called
love finders which precisely connects
people with soulmate
after soulmate after soulmate beth tries
to stop summer from engaging in
app-fueled serial monogamy while jerry
and morty travel to the monogatron
mothership to try and shut the app
down the toilet trespasser turns out to
be a widower named tony
who sees a kindred spirit in rick as
they both need to shy away from the
world during poop time
tony tries to strike up a friendship but
rick isn't down
meanwhile beth finally corners summer
and tries to convince her to stop her
dating bender
luckily jerry has convinced gluti to
sabotage the app by setting up an ad
wall
forcing summer to delete it after
learning that tony has died
rick returns to his toilet and solemnly
reflects on his loneliness
the end for the purposes of this
discussion on love we're going to be
focusing on the b
plot summer's addiction to the dating
app and beth's mission to stop her
the monogatrons are able to so
thoroughly distract humans because
when faced with an abundance of partners
they'll obsessively blow through
relationship after relationship
it's a preamp civilization your love's
value
is defined by scarcity you are highly
trained to seek it
and you have no idea how to maintain it
had you bothered to master love you
would have learned by now it is as
abundant as water
you know what isn't water that
runs out because humanity views love as
a finite resource and our number of
potential partners as limited
earth is easily disrupted when the
monogatrons introduce an app that
connects each person to a soulmate
with terrifying efficiency people don't
just pair up
they leap from partner to partner like
alien frogs on a lily pad
summer goes from dany to jeff to this
devastatingly unhygienic girl
to this dude in no time stupid phones
are destroying us
it's a pretty clear condemnation of
modern dating apps like tinder
okcupid bumble jswipe etc which inundate
users with so many choices
that there's little incentive to invest
in any one relationship
by constantly offering another newer
shinier mate
these apps often either encourage
promiscuity or turn people into serial
three-hour monogamous
compare the modern day tinder hunt for
love with the way earlier generations
found romantic partners
back in agrarian times you pretty much
had the choice of people within your
small town
so if annie or timmy from the farm next
door wasn't your type
you kind of just had to deal love
literally was a scarce resource in a
pre-industrial and
pre-internet world your pool of options
was just smaller
but people still found lifelong
companionship
today you could reject the population of
a small agrarian community in the span
of 60 seconds so if a pre-app society's
vision of love is defined by scarcity we
clearly see that introducing an
infinite number of options is not the
answer but how can an abundance of
choice
negatively affect one's ability to find
love we all want to find the best
partner right to answer that we're
looking to french philosopher alain badu
and specifically his book in praise of
love badu claims that online dating
leads to a risk-free version of love
that erases the possibility of
encountering difference
basically when you have the ability to
algorithmically pick a potential mate by
their political preferences
favorite movies height hair color
socioeconomic background etc
you filter out the possibility of
organically encountering something
you don't know you want it doesn't leave
room for that potential meat cute
we see this with the hyper efficiency of
love finders
the app scans your face and immediately
pairs you with a partner that fits your
every desire
but as we see this love doesn't last
people don't just have
one compatible partner and desire like
most things
changes and people move on to chase the
next desire
so if not personal fulfillment what is
love
for badoo love is more than anything
else a dedication to an idea
as he says love is above all a
construction
that lasts real love is one that
triumphs lastingly
sometimes painfully over the hurdles
erected by time
space and the world sure cinderella can
get swept off her feet by her romantic
encounter with prince charming but
what happens next we assume that they
live happily ever after but in real life
such ephemeral moments rarely last now
what
happily ever after and after that for
badoo
love is about tenacity it's about making
the encounter endure
consider the encounter that started beth
and jerry's relationship
beth accidentally getting pregnant in
high school all this time you've been
thinking
what if that loser jerry hadn't talked
me out of the abortion well now you know
in badoulian terms this would be the
event and yes this event
probably could have been prevented by
proper sex health education
rendering it nowhere near as romantic as
your average disney fair
but that's of little consequence to love
what matters is continued fidelity to
that event
no matter how banal it may be to
continue to say yes in developing the
connection
to perpetuate the relationship in the
face of pain and hardship
that's where true love is forged for
beth this means
ignoring the fact that jerry can't hold
down a job or that he's a total coward
or that he's pretty much the most
superfluous man in the universe
and continue to work through it to
affirm the thing
that brought them together and build off
the initial event
per badoo an apparently insignificant
act but one that is a really radical
event in life at a micro level
bears universal meaning in the way it
persists
and endures this is the perspective beth
is coming from when trying to get summer
off the app
all of summer's encounters evoke your
stereotypical fairy tale connection
you had me at my own name you had me at
hello but in the end
beth asserts the supremacy of badou in
love over the monogatron version
when she checks love finders to see that
it's paired her with boomer dreamboat
ted danson
however instead of pursuing him in all
his silver foxiness
she deletes the app and deepens her
embrace of jerry
love isn't about picking the most viable
candidate out of a dating pool of
millions
it's about making the choice to endure
to quote badu again
strictly speaking love isn't a
possibility but rather the overcoming of
something that might appear to be
impossible
over the last three seasons we've seen
beth and jerry struggle through a
marriage that at many times has seemed
impossible
you both hate yourselves and each other
and yet
somehow they've overcome their
challenges and stayed together
and after their separation during season
three beth now knows
more than ever that real love is born
out of tenacity
at the episodes closed the supposed
superior intimacy of the monogatrons is
proven
false earlier the leader and his partner
seemed like true soul mates
even enjoying the same podcast i found a
new podcast we can listen to tonight
love it but as it turns out that's not
quite enough
and i want a divorce you can have one
for a glass of goddamn water
but what do you guys think is love a
matter of finding the hottest needle in
the haystack
is it about passion and mutual
self-fulfillment or is it about
dedication
and hard work in the face of seemingly
insurmountable
challenges and is this any indication
that the show may be getting more
[Music]
[Applause]
hopeful
[Music]
you